intitulé Les réseaux de la colère
c'était donc le quatrième et dernier
volet de la série ni dieu ni maître une
histoire de l'anarchisme écrit et
réalisé par tancrè dramonaire en
rappelant que le troisième volet de
cette série vous a été proposé à
l'occasion d'un autre débat dock
l'occasion maintenant de s'interroger
sur ce plateau avec nos invités sur le
poids et l'influence qu'à l'anarchisme
aujourd'hui dans notre société avec vous
tout d'abord Edouard Jourdain bienvenue
vous êtes chercheur en théorie politique
spécialiste de la pensée anarchiste
votre dernier ouvrage s'intitule
géopolitique de l'anarchisme vers un
nouveau moment libertaire il a été
publié au Cavalier Bleu et puis on
citera également vous concernant
l'anarchisme ouvrage cette fois publié
chez la découverte Sylvain boulot qui
est également avec nous bienvenue vous
êtes historien spécialiste de
l'anarchisme et du communisme et votre
dernier livre s'intitule lui le peuple
du drapeau noir une histoire des
anarchistes publiées aux éditions Atland
et puis enfin avec nous Christoph pour
essayer bienvenue vous êtes à la fois
historien auteur avec entre autres
plusieurs essais consacrés au courant
extrémiste et minoritaire donc celui-ci
nouvelle histoire de l'ultra gauche
publié aux éditions du Cerf vous étiez
déjà tous les trois avec nous sur ce
même plateau à la suite du troisième
volet de cette série où nous avons
évoqué ensemble ce qui a été finalement
à l'histoire de de l'anarchisme on va
parler maintenant de l'anarchisme
aujourd'hui dans notre société avec
cette première question toute simple
l'anarchisme
influe-t-il aujourd'hui sur les
formations politiques existantes que
nous connaissons à droite à gauche
est-ce que c'est le cas
alors dans cette question il y a déjà
peut-être un paradoxe c'est que les
anarchistes dans leur histoire ils sont
opposés à toute forme de représentation
et donc à ils sont opposés aussi aux
partis politiques précisément qui vont
avoir pour pour but de s'emparer du
pouvoir et de le confisquer en quelque
sorte au peuple pour avoir leur propre
direction idéologiques etc donc il y a
eu je crois peut-être une ou deux
exceptions de quelques anarchistes qu'on
voulait se former en partie mais en
réalité ça jamais véritablement réussi
néanmoins on va retrouver certaines
influences au sein de certains courants
alors quels sont-ils ces courants parce
qu'on a vu que ça avait pu influer sur
l'histoire du Parti socialiste notamment
l'évoquer avec vous à l'émission
précédente Sylvain boulouc quelle
influence pour quel parti politique
existant aujourd'hui s'il fallait
trouver les principales peut-être que
quelques éléments qui pourra compléter
bien évidemment mais il y a évidemment
la dimension écologique qu'on va pouvoir
retrouver chez les Verts qui sont aussi
parfois un petit peu méfiants sur un
système centralisé étatique etc il y a
les dimensions parfois d'autogestion
qu'on va pouvoir retrouver dans certains
courants de parties comme comme on NPA
par exemple
à partir de avec plusieurs tendances
différentes donc une assez minoritaire
mais qui se réclame de l'anarchisme
aussi en tout cas libertaire mais donc
vous envoyez d'autres super boulot chez
les Verts et restent alors pour deux
raisons c'est à dire qu'il y a un
certain nombre d'anciens libertaires à
l'image de donner une gobendide
justement avant qu'il ne verse dans le
parti présidentiel actuel mais comme on
dit de se réclamait enfin importer chez
les Verts une tradition libertaire et
quand on regarde la composition et la
formation des verres en France on voit
qu'il y a des influences libertaires il
y a pas mal d'anciens libertaires qui
pourrix ou y raison ont quitté la
mouvance commentaires pour se rapprocher
des vers par souci d'efficacité parce
que il considérait il y avait des
moments où il fallait passer en passer
par la voix électorale donc il y a ce
premier noyau on en retrouverait un peu
également aux parties socialiste pour un
peu les mêmes raisons d'anciens
libertaires qui la mouvance libertaire
pour pour la même raison aussi
d'efficacité et qui conserve des traces
de leur passé
dans dans l'appareil politique qu'il
fréquente à ce moment-là
après il y a aussi le mot par exemple si
on joue sur la France insoumise alors la
France insoumise c'est une référence à
la fois à la chanson de Jean Ferrat avec
qui a inventé le champ la France mais il
y a aussi le côté insoumis et là le côté
insoumi fait et Mélenchon à plusieurs
reprises dans ces discours pendant la
campagne présidentielle faisait
référence à ses amis anarchistes qu'il
appelait à voter là on est pratiquement
dans le paradoxe mais toujours est-il
qu'il y a cette dimension du refus de
l'ordre et du refus de l'autorité qui
est présent dans ce dans cette formation
avec deuxième chose alors la pseudo
horizontalité qui existerait dans dans
la France insoumise donc on retrouve pas
de l'anarchisme en tant que corps
doctrinal mais des pratiques libertaires
qui peuvent diffuser et se distiller
dans dans la société et dans un certain
nombre de partis politiques plutôt à
gauche quand même de l'échiquier
politique elle faisait le même constat
là on est dans les mouvances de gauche
dans les formations politiques je dirais
que c'est plus plutôt que dans les
parties je dirais qu'il y a une
influence libertaire au niveau
associatif c'est-à-dire que il y a
quelque chose qui s'est passé
fondamentalement au début du 21e siècle
c'est le fait que beaucoup d'anarchistes
ont cessé de se revendiquer comme tel
ils ont laissé tomber l'étiquette on
considérant que anarchiste s'adaptait du
XIXe siècle c'était fini et en fait il
ne voulait plus d'étiquettes mais ils
sont restés des libertaires ils sont
restés anti-autoritaire et ils ont joué
un rôle considérable dans toute ce
mouvement associatif
environnementaliste parallèle à
l'écologie officielle alors je veux
parler par exemple il y a un truc un
phénomène fondamental dans laquelle ils
ont un rôle de déclencheur c'est le
phénomène des ADDES ce qu'on appelle les
as les zones zone à défendre ou zone
d'autonomie défensive ou zone
d'autonomie durable parce que l'acronyme
se prête à plusieurs interprétations ce
sont des libertés au départ qui sont à
la création des ADDES des gens
issus de l'autonomie
issue des courants sites
prostituationnistes
issus des courants libertaires qui ont
choisi de déserter les villes ils
avaient lu un auteur qui s'appelle Hakim
bai qui avait créé un livre qui
s'appelait tas temporary autonomoot zone
dans lequel il appelait à créer dans les
villes des zones d'autonomie temporaires
ou on échappe au contrôle de l'État et
ils se sont dit à la campagne on peut
créer des zones d'autonomie temporaire
et c'est ainsi qu'on vue le jour les
ades qui sont en fait des zones
d'autonomie temporaire en plein milieu
de la nature
là il y a une vraie expérience
libertaire de masse qui se fait que ce
soit Notre Dame des Landes à sainte-soly
enfin toutes les toutes les 6-20 les
nombreuses ades qui ont fleuri ou qui
fleurissent encore ces derniers temps ça
c'est très important et ça c'est
véritablement l'héritage associatif de
l'anarchisme on avait vu avec vous tout
à l'heure qui a défaut de s'investir
dans le domaine politique
d'avoir de la pétance pour les
démocraties parlementaires par exemple
les anarchistes tout au long de leur
histoire ce sont investis dans les
syndicats justement vous vous évoquiez
alors ce sont les Bourses du travail
notamment et puis des syndicats dit
révolutionnaires est-ce que c'est encore
le cas aujourd'hui et ce qu'on trouve
trace aujourd'hui de l'anarchisme dans
l'activité syndicale en France
oui certainement alors juste pour faire
un tout petit point d'histoire
d'ailleurs la CGT à l'origine et
d'inspiration largement alors
syndicalistes révolutionnaire mais aussi
un Arcos syndicaliste où on retrouve ces
principes d'autogestion qui avait été
mis en valeur déjà par certains
socialisme libertaire avec Proudhon etc
et puis c'est en réalité qu'avec la
révolution bolchevik qui va y avoir un
tournant donc ça vient de très très loin
et alors aujourd'hui
alors je suis je suis pas un spécialiste
et peut-être que si vous avez été plus
de boulot mais il y a dans certains
syndicats particulièrement je pense par
exemple la Sud qui a été beaucoup
investie par par des anarchistes
tout à fait
CFDT qui avait aussi
une lignée
alors chrétienne socialiste parfois anar
avec cette thématique de l'autogestion
etc mais avec ici avec le syndicat comme
sud une forme de radicalisation
libertaire parfois dépassant en termes
de radicalité la CGT qui avait un petit
peu le monopole de la du changement
social dans le mouvement syndical
français actuel on retrouve des des
centrales syndicales expressément
syndicaliste révolutionnaire ou anarchos
syndicaliste comme elles sont trois
maintenant c'est donc ça devient
compliqué on va dire les CNT
effectivement dans dans Sud depuis sa
création enfin maintenant c'est
solidaire depuis sa création il y a eu
notamment au CRC santé social et à Sud
PTT il y avait et aussi à Sud cheminots
il y avait un certain nombre de liberté
qui était présent qui n'était pas les
seuls mais qui ont exporté leur pratique
libertaire dans le mouvement syndical
rappelant l'héritage historique de du
syndicalisme révolutionnaire matinée de
d'anarchisme
avec peloutier le débat sur
l'indépendance du syndicalisme qui
existe également dans deux autres
centrales syndicales qui sont plus
importantes d'une part la CGT ou la CGT
alors même si elle a été pendant très
longtemps sous contrôle du Parti
communiste a toujours eu un problème
avec un texte fondateur qui est la
Charte d'Amiens qui définissait deux
choses d'abord l'autonomie du mouvement
syndical par rapport aux partis
politiques et puis deuxième chose comme
objectif final la grève générale pour
exproprier le patronat donc dans la CGT
il y avait cette question là avec
l'ambiguïté de son rapport avec le Parti
communiste et on le retrouve également
dans une autre centrale syndicale qui
est importante qui est la CGT Force
Ouvrière puisque une scission en fait
Force Ouvrière s'appelle la CGT Force
ouvrière et dans la CGT Force Ouvrière
comme dans la CGT de
l'entre-deux-guerres il y a toujours eu
un courant syndicaliste libertaire qui a
existé dans lequel qui représentait à
peu près 10% des effectifs mais dans
lequel on retrouve un certain nombre de
libertaire alors le plus anecdotique est
le plus amusant c'est mur et joyeux qui
était une figure emblématique de la
fédération narciste qui a été pendant
très longtemps approche d'André Bergeron
donc le secrétaire fait considéral de la
CGT FO et qui a même participé à la au
Conseil économique et social ou ici j'ai
eu la siégé un temps donc il y a
toujours eu dans l'ensemble du mouvement
syndical on peut aussi parler de
l'éducation des tendances enfin les
différentes
dépendances libertaires jamais été
majoritaires mais elles ont toujours
existé dans le mouvement syndical en
France et en tous les cas sur un point
très important qui est la définition de
l'autonomie du mouvement syndical par
rapport aux particules politiques alors
il y a aussi des courants anti
syndicalistes on le voit par exemple
quand est-ce qu'il y a des
manifestations syndicales il arrive
parfois que des Autonomes attaquent les
camionnettes de la CGT c'est pas du tout
gratuit c'est parce que il s'inspire
d'une tradition anti syndicaliste qui
dit que les syndicats encadre la classe
ouvrière les syndicats sur des courroies
de transmission du capitalisme et qui
défendent l'idée des grèves sauvages
donc des grèves anti-syndicales donc il
y a aussi sous courant là qui faut pas
négliger qui perturent bien évidemment
et qu'on retrouve partiellement au sein
du mouvement des gilets jaunes sur le
les modes opératoires alors c'est vrai
que il s'est mis en avant dans ce
documentaire il y a les fameux Black
Bloc c'est un mode opératoire les
black-box c'est pas un groupe déterminé
et ça va être tout notre sujet
d'ailleurs alors dans ce documentaire il
est rappelé que c'est en 99 qu'on a
surtout parlé des Black Blocs c'est pas
en France c'était au sommet de
l'Organisation mondiale du commerce à 7h
on a vu ces images dans dans ce film
présence des Black Blocs plaisance aussi
des médias et tout cela évidemment a
fait monter ce mode opératoire sur les
écrans de télé c'est assez spectaculaire
c'est un mode opératoire très très fort
d'un point de vue visuel et qui plus est
ces hommes et ces femmes sont habillées
en noir
est-ce que dans ces fameux Black Blocs
se trouve aujourd'hui une grande partie
d'un artiste
alors oui bien sûr il y a une grande
partie je sais pas mais en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il y a une partie
d'anarchiste aussi de ce qu'on appelle
des autonomes qui sont sans étiquette
véritable etc
bonarchistes qui refusent l'étiquette
anarchiste
mais en effet donc il y a ces
anarchistes alors on le voit l'image et
il y a cette idée de propagande par le
fait aussi dans dans cette tactique le
fait de détruire des banques des des
symboles du symbole du capitalisme du
pouvoir du capitalisme
donc il y a cette idée en effet de
de faire circuler cette image qu'on peut
finalement porter atteinte à ce qui ne
ce qui paraît ininténiable bon donc il y
a ce côté un peu j'allais dire un peu
marketing en tout cas du visuel de
marquer etc d'ailleurs dans le dans le
documentaire c'est intéressant de voir
aussi que les anarchistes y compris par
le Acer clé il y a cette idée de de
faire circuler des symboles donc il y a
toujours une attention à l'image qui est
très importante quand même peuvent faire
mettre un signe égalité entre black bloc
mode opératoire black bloc et anarchiste
il faut peut-être dans les Black Blocs
il y a plusieurs dimensions en fait
d'abord il y a une chose historique qui
est amusante c'est qu'en fait le Black
Bloc c'est une affiche enfin un groupe
d'archiste allemand qui n'a rien à voir
si manifestait c'est des anarchistes
allemands qui avaient constitué un
groupe qui s'appelait le bloc noir qui
manifestait visage découvert ils avaient
juste une membrane c'est par la suite ou
des antifascistes
un groupe libertaire tout à fait lambda
non même pas ils avaient il s'appelait
le groupe Noir enfin le bloc noir et
puis après très rapidement un bloc
anarchiste mais très rapidement vous
avez des autonomes qui sont couverts la
tête et qui ont commencé à affronter les
forces de l'ordre et les forces de
l'ordre ont repris l'étiquette en disant
voilà ça c'est le bloc noir couvrant
tout le spectre de la gauche radicale et
l'anarchisme en disant tous ceux qui
affrontent les forces de l'ordre le
visage le visage masqués sont sont des
Black Blocs l'expression s'est répandue
à partir de Siatel en
1999 et depuis dans chaque manifestation
il y a un côté société du spectacle
aussi puisque le Black Bloc va
spectaculairement attaquer un certain
nombre de symboles du capitalisme en
sachant qu'ils sont filmés par des
caméras capitalistes également mais il y
a cette dimension qui est présente de
vouloir démontrer par une forme de
nouvelle forme de propagande par le fait
que il y a des cas des oppositions
capitalistes alors après quand on
regarde les participants au Black Bloc
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
hétérogène puisqu'on a aussi bien
effectivement quelques libertaires même
si tous les anarchistes font pas partie
du Black Bloc on s'en fout mais on a
quelques libertaires mais on a aussi des
groupes d'extrême gauche
néo-maoiistes des
autonomes et puis on peut même retrouver
mais ils vont pas l'afficher et
ouvertement mais on peut retrouver un
certain nombre de militants de gauche
radicales de formation qui peuvent le
cas échéant participer à ce type
d'action ou à d'autres types d'actions
aux marches de la légalité on comprendra
qu'après ils n'ont pas forcément envie
de revendiquer parce que il peut y avoir
des poursuites judiciaires mais c'est un
mode opérateur auquel participent des
anarchistes mais qui n'est pas à
identifier à l'anarchie je suis pas tout
à fait d'accord c'est quand même le mode
opératoire de libertaire absolue
c'est-à-dire on refuser de marcher ou
pas refuser de manifester comme des
boutons derrière une banderole créer un
cortège de tête informel
anti-autoritaire insurrectionnel et sans
prendre au symbole du capitalisme c'est
une démarche entre guillemets
révolutionnaire à ses types et qui
remonte à loin c'est pas du tout un
phénomène récent vous avez daté satiété
mais en réalité ça démarre non ça
démarre des images de skattle dans ce
dock ça a démarré en 1971 lorsque des
militants libertaires ont fait
volontairement le pillage du quartier
latin pour montrer qu'une vraie
manifestation révolutionnaire c'est
aussi à piller ça consistait à frapper
les symboles du capital en cassant les
vitrines etc et à partir de là vous avez
eu dans toutes les manifestations de
gauche syndicale ou étudiantes ou
lycéenne vous avez vu apparaître des
groupes informels de gens plus ou moins
masqués qui se réclamaient donnaient
beaucoup de tracts d'ailleurs qui était
toujours des tracts d'inspiration post
situation
d'inspiration libertaire et puis à
partir de 1975 ils se sont fait appeler
les autonomes parce que ils se sont
alliés avec d'anciens maoïstes et que
toute façon il refusaient tout étiquette
ils étaient dans le dépassement des
ismes comme ils disaient et au fond
aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
sont les héritiers de ça donc c'est une
presque une tradition du mouvement
ouvrier aujourd'hui de voir ces gens qui
sont en marche maintenant là où je
rejoins Sylvain c'est que effectivement
quand vous prenez le mouvement
anarchiste officiel vous avez les trois
quarts des anarchistes officielles sont
contre ces autonomes en disant nous on
manifeste derrière nos banderoles on
veut faire passer nos idées on n'est pas
d'accord avec le fait de s'en prendre un
peu au hasard ou commerçant ou tout ça
donc effectivement vous avez et avec un
drapeau noir plutôt que d'être habillé
intégralement ils ont des drapeaux noirs
aussi donc vous avez vous avez
effectivement un anarchisme officielle
et puis vous avez ce qu'on appelle en
réalité aujourd'hui les autonomes de
façon très imprécise mais qui sont
fondamentalement
structurés par la une pensée libertaire
alors on assimile aussi souvent mais on
est là pour ça pour peut-être tordre le
coup à certaines idées reçues
ultra gauche et anarchie c'est pas
pareil or c'est c'est pas pareil si le
boulot que Édouard Jourdain moi enfin de
manière très
rapide en terme un peu fin d'histoire
des idées moi j'ai enfin l'ultra gauche
elle va être surtout marquée par le par
le marxisme aussi alors que dans
l'anarchisme c'est un petit peu
différent il y a ce côté on peut pas
être catégorisé y compris sur le spectre
politique qui est
issu de la division entre partie après
la Révolution française donc les
anarchistes vont pas s'inscrire déjà
dans cette dans cette environnement
symbolique dans lesquels on aimerait les
inscrire
encore quelque part parce que vous voyez
vous avez fait une remarque tout à
l'heure ça a l'air qu'on lorsqu'on
regarde un peu plus précisément les
choses aujourd'hui le terme anarchisme
et anarchiste figure assez peu à
comparer au terme ultra gauche
simplement debout c'est que l'ultra
gauche au départ c'est un courant
marxiste
antilléniniste qui est apparu après la
Révolution d'Octobre qui a perduré
jusqu'à aujourd'hui mais simplement dans
la bouche des policiers des journalistes
et tous est devenu une sorte d'étiquette
pour désigner à peu près tout ce qui est
très à gauche donc aujourd'hui vous avez
un attentat commis par des maoïs on va
dire c'est un attentat ultra gauche
alors évidemment ça n'a rien à voir oui
il y a un problème sémantique assez
c'est important déjà il y a la double
étiquette anarchiste et libertaire
souvent l'anarchisme faisant plus peur
le terme utilisé c'est libertaire par
exemple il y a un exemple qui est tout à
fait révélateur la majorité de la presse
anarchiste libertaire partisan de la
liberté absolue tout ça mais la majorité
de la presse anarchiste a comme titre
libertaire avec un qualificatif quel
qu'il soit mais libertaire plutôt
qu'unarchiste comme si ça faisait un peu
repoussoir les titres avec juste un
archiste ont rarement marché très très
longtemps c'est négatif après
effectivement il y a vocabulaire
médiatique qui fait que tout est mélangé
dans tout donc tout ce qui est la gauche
extra parlementaire au-delà de la France
insoumise on va dire rejoint l'ultra
gauche alors effectivement dans ultra
gauche il y a les derniers les derniers
mawist ou résurgence du maïs des
déconseillistes alors les conseillers
sera envoyant à effectivement au débat
qui avait dans le marxisme poste
révolution russe entre les partisans de
Luxembourg puis un certain nombre
d'autres critiques du léninisme qui eux
ont eu l'étiquette originelle du travaux
plus après se joignent les courants des
années 70 qui ont critiqué les formes de
parties et qui rejoignent cette
cette mouvance révolutionnaire dans
lequel effectivement il y a des
pratiques qui ressemblent à des
pratiques libertaires mais dans lequel
un certain nombre d'individus ne sont
pas du tout libertaires dans ce film
tancrait de ramoner dit finalement les
anarchistes sont partout et nulle part
est-ce que c'est pas un peu ça le
problème des anarchistes aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui est aussi leur force c'est
à dire que depuis surtout depuis nos
vingtaine d'années en gros depuis la
chute du mur de Berlin pour faire vite
le le début de ce qu'on va appeler
l'altermondialisme etc on va voir
beaucoup de pratiques qui sont en
réalité
d'inspiration anarchisme et qui sont en
fait assez naturels et que les
anarchistes vont théoriser qui sont tout
simplement des formes de d'autonomie
d'autogestion d'entraide de à de
politique directe d'organisation de
réappropriation des choses pour les
distribuer collectivement etc bon et ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on va retrouver
dans beaucoup de mouvements qui ne se
réclament pas anarchiste et moi il m'est
arrivé de rencontrer des personnes alors
notamment dans le milieu associatif
particulièrement au sein d'ailleurs
d'une d'un mouvement qui est de plus en
plus important qui est repris aussi en
termes d'idées politiques économique qui
s'appelle les communs qui est une notion
qui qui remonte en réalité depuis les
débuts de l'histoire de l'humanité qui
consiste pour tout simplement pour un
groupe
de s'organiser de manière autonome et de
gérer des ressources en commun donc
c'est quelque chose de très simple sans
que ce soit avec le marché ni avec
l'État c'est quelque chose qui a été
beaucoup théorisé notamment par la prix
Nobel d'économie et du Nord au Strom
mais c'est quelque chose qu'on va
retrouver de manière informelle et très
importantes dans beaucoup d'associations
de mouvements etc et qui en réalité sont
très proches des théories et des
pratiques anarchistes donc moi ça m'est
arrivé que il y a des personnes qui me
disent mais alors du coup c'est quoi
l'anarchisme etc qui avait vu des des
articles ou des livres que j'avais pu
écrire qui se dit mais en fait dans ma
pratique je me suis rendu compte que
j'étais anarchiste donc c'est simplement
ils avaient pas mis les mots sur sur la
pratique mais c'est peut-être ça qu'on
essaye de comprendre on a du mal
semble-t-il à se revendiquer anarchiste
aujourd'hui les gens qui veulent se
revendiquer l'archistes peuvent se
revendiquer anarchistes même les lois
scélérates ont été abolies il y a fin de
l'année une trentaine d'années donc il y
a pas de problème légaux à ce où il y
avait pas de problème à se réclamer
après le mot est entouré et chargé d'une
certaine histoire ce qui fait
qu'effectivement contrairement à
d'autres formations politiques qui
pourraient avoir des problèmes avec leur
passé on peut penser au communisme par
exemple le mois de marché se pose plus
de problèmes parce que ça veut dire
partisans c'est tout en mbiguïté du
terme et ils font l'ambiguïté fondatrice
du terme c'est anarchie est à la fois un
courant politique mais étant même temps
associé à la notion de désordre
tout à l'heure en plaisantant on disait
on était tous en train de parler
ensemble on disait c'est l'anarchie donc
il y a toujours cette cette double
ambiguïté qui fait que effectivement ça
renvoie une pratique qui est une
pratique sociale qui est une pratique de
solidarité au quotidien qui sont des
pratiques que qui peuvent se retrouver
dans l'anarchisme mais qui ne
définissent pas en tant que tel
anarchiste donc qui a cette ambivalence
permanente mais qui est depuis l'origine
un des problèmes majeurs des anarchistes
qui d'autre part il faut le rappeler
aussi bah forcément beaucoup
l'organisation donc se réclamer
d'anarchisme être organisé quand on est
archi ça sous-entend déjà une discipline
que les
anarchistes ont du mal à s'appliquer à
eux-mêmes ce qui est aussi un autre un
autre problème fondamental pour les
anarchistes aujourd'hui Christophe
Bourseiller j'ai lu quelque part que les
gilets jaunes pouvaient être assimilés à
des anarchistes que ce mouvement pouvait
être un mouvement anarchiste ça nous
refus de la verticalité c'est là où
peut-être c'est dans le refus de la
verticalité il y a quelque chose qui est
intéressant parce que on n'a pas besoin
d'être nombreux pour avoir de
l'influence est-ce que moi m'a enseigné
l'observation des courants minoritaires
et ce qui est intéressant avec les
anarchistes c'est le fait qu'au fond ils
sont diffusés un certain nombre de
pratiques et d'idées de façon virale
vous voyez on est dans une société de
plus en plus horizontale on cherche des
modes d'organisation horizontale des
modes d'organisation en réseau dans
lesquels il y a de plus en plus
d'auto-organisations des gens au niveau
local et localisation
mais ça c'est l'influence diffuse des
idées anarchistes vous voyez alors
évidemment les gilets jaunes c'était une
sorte de Miles Rome vous vend social de
douleur de de de gens qui étaient
malheureux pour des raisons très
diverses et un mélange de colère mais
c'est vrai que dans le côté
individualisme de ses colères on pouvait
trouver un écho anarchiste parce que
l'anarchisme au départ c'est le refus de
toute autorité mais c'est aussi l'idée
de la Libération individuelle et donc
c'est vrai que dans l'individualisme des
gilets jaunes on pouvait retrouver une
part on pourrait dire de cet élan
individuel sans que vous avez envie de
réagir
je rejoins Christophe il y a une
dimension individuelle mais qui est
aussi collective et c'est ça qu'on a
retrouvé aussi chez les gilets jaunes
sur les rassemblements autour des
ronds-points etc il y a eu les les
assemblées à aussi qui était des formes
aussi de de démocratie directe avec des
prises de parole des débats etc donc qui
s'inscrivent complètement en effet dans
la dans la tradition anarchiste mais là
finalement mais alors est-ce qu'on
devient pas le temps anarchiste c'est ça
la question enfin du du mouvement des
gilets jaunes enfin en l'occurrence
c'était pas un mouvement anarchiste en
tant que tel mais il y avait des
pratiques anarchistes alors avec des
idées qui ne coïncidaient pas toujours
nécessairement avec les idanarchistes ou
on avait des des complotistes des
réactionnaires des tout ce que vous
voulez bon mais mais
on retrouvait en tout cas enfin une
révolte à mon avis collective et sociale
contre certaines formes de d'injustice
et certaines pratiques en tout cas
d'auto-organisation qui rejoignait
l'anarchisme à ce niveau-là il faut
faire très attention en histoire et 6
ans ce mouvement effectivement dès le
départ il y a eu quelques groupes comme
un Commercy comme autour de Nantes ou et
gilets jaunes étaient proches des
pratiques libertaires se greffait sur
une colère après quand on regarde les
premières manifestations des gilets
jaunes en mois de octobre
novembre pardon 2018 il y a quand même
un certain nombre de slogans qui sont en
opposition complète avec les idées et
les pratiques libertaires c'est on est
chez nous quand on regarde un certain
nombre de ronds-points ils étaient quand
même tenus par
si on regarde le spectre politique
l'extrême droite de l'échiquier
politique dans le sud-ouest de la France
et c'est ce qu'on va retrouver aussi
chez alors c'est tout problème aussi
antivax et anti anti-pasanitaire
c'est-à-dire que vous la dimension
anti-passanitaire pouvait rejoindre une
pratique libertaire une définition
libertaire en disant on veut pas de
contrainte la définition antiox posait
plus de problèmes parce que il y a quand
même le penser aux autres qui est
présent dans la pensée libertaire à
savoir la solidarité on va pas
contaminer quelqu'un parce que parce
qu'on fait ce qu'on veut il y a
l'altérité la solidarité l'entraide
c'est un livre de crocodile qui date du
19e siècle mais qui est une qui est une
pratique libertaire extrêmement
importante donc l'entraide c'est pas à
donner une maladie à son voisin comme ça
donc autant on peut voir la dimension
anti rcive et anti dans les
antipastanitaires autant chez les
antivax je serai beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus réticent et c'est la même chose
chez gilet jaune au départ c'est pas ça
par la suite effectivement à partir du
mois de la fin novembre début décembre
il y a de plus en plus de pratique
libertaire qui apparaissent mais aussi
parce que le nombre de participants au
mouvement des gilets jaunes et diminue
donc ce qui reste c'est les noyaux les
plus militants
l'anarchisme de droite aujourd'hui on a
beaucoup parlé de l'influence que peut
avoir plus ou moins
l'anarchisme encore aujourd'hui sur les
mouvances de gauche on n'a pas évoqué de
telle influence sur l'émouvances de
droite et pourtant elle existe bah oui
évidemment il y a un anarchisme de
droite on en a parlé lors de la dernière
émission c'est un anarchiste qui
s'appuie sur la encore des Michels on a
encore vous évoquiez lors de la
précédente
de cet héritage de Michel audierge
aujourd'hui tour il y avait encore
jusqu'il y a peu un club des ronchons
qui se réunissaient bonarchiste parce
que sympathique de bistrot plutôt
amusant après vous avez des anarchistes
assez étranges par exemple il y a dans
la mouvance de d'Éric Zemmour un
anarchisme chrétien qui s'est créé
à cause de Jacques de Guillebon qui se
déclare mais très à droite de
l'échiquier politique droite et qui se
déclare anarchiste
en défendant un anarchisme chrétien de
droite vous avez évidemment un certain
nombre d'individualises et pourtant ni
Dieu animait être ni Dieu ni dieu ni
maître mais c'est pas le cas là
effectivement mais vous avez aussi des
anarchistes chrétiens de gauche on
parlait tout à l'heure de léontolstoï on
en aurait pu citer beaucoup d'autres
gens il y a des groupes chrétiens un
arco-chrétiens vous savez le problème de
l'anarchie c'est qu'on le met à toutes
les sauces puisqu'en fait comme on le
disait l'anarchie si vous ouvrez le
Littré celle des ordres l'anarchisme
c'est une doctrine qui lutte contre
toute autorité à partir de là on met ce
qu'on veut là-dedans chacun est libre de
faire son petit cocktail anarchiste et
évidemment c'est embêtant pour les
anarchistes officiels parce que
défendent des doctrines qui sont
structurées établies proudienne
bakuninienne syndicaliste
révolutionnaire ou un archos salariés à
2 minutes je vous propose de vous les
partager pour finir oui non et puis
c'est ce qui fait tout tout le charme et
l'intérêt de l'anarchisme aussi c'est de
pas être enfermé dans un dans un système
des doctrines qui peuvent pas bouger etc
et donc après il y a évidemment plein de
doctrines autour qui peuvent gravité sur
le christianisme ça me fait penser à la
je crois que c'était Malraux qui disait
Jésus est un anarchiste qui a réussi
c'est le sol bon il y a voilà il y a
cette tradition aussi il y a sans parler
nécessairement de droite il y a aussi un
anarchisme conservateur ou l'anarchisme
théorie dans des sociétés telles que la
nôtre ou l'individualisme est tout de
même de plus en plus présent c'est le
sentiment que ça donne en tout cas on
pourrait penser que l'anarchisme va y
trouver toute sa place mais bon oui non
parce qu'il y a l'anarchisme repose
comme on l'a dit en l'autre émission sur
quatre antis fondamentaux qui sont à
l'antiétatisme l'anticapitalisme
l'antiquités religiosité d'une manière
générale toute forme d'autorité en fait
et capitaliste pour l'anarchisme de
gauche et bon qu'est-ce qui est
maintenant ce qui est plus réellement
lieu d'être mais qui était aussi l'aNTIC
au sens soviétique du terme avec à côté
de ça quand même un autre corps qui
faisait le lien le lion
anti-colonialisme anticholonialisme et
ce qui faisait le lien entre les
libertaires à travers les âges qui
étaient les pratiques de solidarité les
pratiques d'entraide les pratiques
d'échanges donc à partir du moment où on
commence à dire on est que dans une
société d'individus si ces individus ne
sont plus reliés entre eux ils ne sont
plus solidaires est-ce qu'on est
réellement déjà même dans l'anarchisme
individualisme j'en doute et est-ce
qu'on est dans l'anarchisme réellement
j'en doute encore plus c'est à dire que
c'est il y a quand même derrière quand
la notion d'anarchisme encore plus
doctrinal avec une multitude
d'interprétation mais il y a quand même
un corpus doctrinal qui existe qui
repose sur un certain nombre de lectures
on a commencé par prodo qui vont
jusqu'au syndicaliste avec une multitude
de dimensions qui fait à la fois le
charme et la pluralité de cette
anarchisme social qui est qui est un
corps de Trinité
c'est un aiguillon lourd de signaux
faibles dans le très rapidement c'est
vraiment la finalisation faut pas
comprendre à anarchisme et libéralisme
le libéralisme c'est en effet le règne
de l'individu seul isolé l'anarchiste
c'est la
coïncidence de l'individu et du
collectif ou du social et voilà c'est
dit merci un grand merci d'avoir été
avec nous non seulement pour cette
émission mais pour l'autre émission que
nous avons consacrée cette fois ce qui
était le troisième volet de cette
fresque historique écrite et réalisée
par Tancrède ramonais vous pouvez bien
sûr réagir à cette émission sur hashtag
des Badoc sur Twitter merci également à
sel massali qui comme à l'accoutumée m'a
aidé à préparer cette émission prochain
rendez-vous avec des badox ça sera bien
sûr avec son documentaire et son débat à
très bientôt
[Musique]